تستمر في فرنسا احتجاجات واعمال عنف على
خلفيه مقتل شاب فرنسي من اصول جزائريه
برصاص الشرطه الامر الذي دعا الرئيس
ماكرون لقطع مشاركته في قمه اوروبيه
والعوده لتراس خليه ازمه في بلاده وفي وقت
قالت فيه رئيسه الوزراء الفرنسيه ان
الخيارات مفتوحه في التعامل مع الاحداث
اعتبرتها الامم المتحده فرصه لمعالجه
مشاكل العنصريه والتمييز
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف تبدو خيارات
الحكومه الفرنسيه وخطابها في التعامل مع
الاحتجاجات والى اي مدى تملك القياده
والمؤسسات السياسيه الفرنسيه فرصه
احتوائها وايجاد حلولا جذريه لها في اي
سياق يمكن ان نضع هذه الموجه الجديده من
الاحتجاجات واي علاقه لها باخرى سابقه مثل
احتجاجات السترات الصفراء واي دلالات تشير
الى التصاعد الغضب الاجتماعي في البلاد اي
مستقبلا ينتظر المشهدين الاجتماعي
والسياسي في فرنسا بالنظر الى دعوات من
الامم المتحده وغيرها لايجاد حلول عميقه
للعنصريه ومخاطر تفاقمها داخل اجهزه
الدوله
[موسيقى]
هزه اجتماعيه اخرى تمر بها فرنسا في عهد
الرئيس لمنويل ماكرون وحكومته ذات
السياسات المثيره للجدل وللاحتجاجات
الساخنه بين حين واخر هذه المره اصطبغت
التظاهرات الغاضبه بلون الدم بعد ان خرجت
احتجاجا على مقتل شاب فرنسي من اصول
جزائريه برصاص احد عناصر الشرطه الفرنسيه
اختلطت الاحتجاجات السلميه باعمال العنف
تماما كما اختلطت في التصريحات الرسميه
عبارات التهدئه باخرى تتوعد بالحزم في فرض
الامن وبين هذا وذاك فرنسا التي يقض
استقرارها جدل ساخن حد العنف بشان سياسات
رسميه يمتد قوسها من اداره السلطه وتوزيع
الثروه الى العنصريه وقضايا الاندماج او
الاولويه الان فيما يبدو من خطاب الرئيس
ماكرون تبقى لاستعاده الامن وبعدها
حديث لاحداث قديمه جديده نتابع جانبا مما
قاله الرئيس الفرنسي
امام هذه الاحداث اتخذنا القرار بالغاء
عدد من الفعاليات والانشطه والتجمعات في
البلديات والمناطق والمؤسسات الحساسه
بعموم البلاد من اجل حمايه مواطنين كما
انه سيتم التعامل بحزم مع كل من يقوم
باعمال نهب او يهاجم مؤسسات الدوله وهنا
ندعو جميع الاباء لتحمل مسؤولياتهم ازاء
ابنائهم واذا الدوله ومؤسساتها لانه ثبت
بعد التحقيق ان ثلث المعتقلين الليله
الماضيه هم من المراهقين وهذه مسؤوليه
اولياء الامور
ثم من متحده لحقوق الانسان اعتبر ما يحدث
فرصه لفرنسا لتعالج بجديه المشكلات
العميقه المتعلقه بالعنصريه والتمييز
العنصري في انفاذ القانون مشددا على ضروره
ان تلتزم الاحتجاجات السلميه والشرطه
والشرطه القانون في التعامل معه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
فرانس رئيس منظمه عداله وحقوق بلا حدود من
باريس ايضا معنا جيرالد اوليفيي الباحث في
العلاقات الاوروبيه والدوليه ومن جنيف
معنى الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جنيف مرحبا بكم جميعا
سنبدا معك عندما تقول السلطات الفرنسيه ان
جميع الخيارات يتم بحثها لوقف هذه الاعمال
الجاريه ماذا نتوقع
في الحقيقه وفي المقام الاول المهم
بالنسبه الى الشرطه الفرنسيه هو احلال
النظام والهدوء في الدواحي ومنذ ثلاث
الليالي نحن نشهد فوضى عارمه في هذه
المنطقه طبعا من السهوله بمكان ان نقول
ذلك ولكن التنفيذ يبقى اصعب نحن نتحدث عن
ضروره استجابه من قبل الشرطه ونحن نتحدث
عن مشكله في فرنسا منذ عقود لسبب او لاخر
تحصل هذه الاعمال التي بالنسبه الي ليست
سياسيه بل اساسها اجتماعي ونتحدث عن اشخاص
يخربون وعندما نرى
الشخصيه شخصيه نائل هذا الشاب البالغ من
العمر السابع عشره اذا لم يكن لديه قياده
السياره وكان يخالف النظام العام
وارتكب اثنتي عشره مخالفه من قبل في سن
السابعه عشره اذا لم يقبل بالامتثال
لاوامر الشرطه ولذلك تتعامل الشرطه مع
اشخاص لا يحترمون القوانين الجمهوريه وفي
الوقت نفسه هناك هجمات الان في الضواحي
ويستفيدون من اي حادث لاشحال المنطقه يعني
ما قلت ان
الفتى نائل ارتكبه هل يستحق القتل من وجهه
نظرك
كلا هذا لم اقل هذا ابدا انا لم اقل ان
قتل نائل مبرر ولكننا نتحدث عن امور تحصل
نتحدث عن هجمات على الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
وهناك تفلت واشخاص يتصرفون كقطاع طرق في
بعض الاحيان وهنا في هذا الحادث نتحدث عن
نقطه تفتيش مروريه وهو امر اعتيادي يحصل
في فرنسا ويجب الامتثال لاوامر رجال
الشرطه هؤلاء لا يحترمون القوانين ويخرقون
القوانين الفرنسيه لا يمتثلنا لي اوامر
رجال الشرطه وفي بعض الاحيان تحصل هذه
التبعات انا لا ابرر ما حصل ولكن
السيد
اذا هناك هجمات تجري على جمهوريه الفرنسيه
من يقوم بهذه الهجمات
لا يمتثلون للقوانين وهذا ما قاله ضيفنا
السيد جيرالد اوليفيا ولكن في نفس السياق
تحدث الرئيس الفرنسي هو قال اليوم في معرض
ادانته لهذه الاعمال اعمال العنف الجاريه
ان الوضع حصل ان هذا الوضع يقول الرئيس
الفرنسي وراءه جماعات منظمه وعنيفه
ومجهزه ما رايك
بونجور
مساء انتم مشاهديكم وضيوفكم على ضيفكم
الاخر ليس موجود ليدافع عن نفسه نائل لا
اعرف ان رايتم
لابد ان نحترم الامر ولابد ان نحترم هذا
الوفاه هذا الرجل الذي اغتيل والشيء
الثاني تتحدثين عن ان كان السوابق في
الشرطه وان ان المدرسه حاله نائل واسرته
من حيث مبدا ليس لديه سجل اجرامي سابق
مليء كما قالت بعض شبكات التلفزيون وايضا
تعرفونها اضطرابات تعرفون هناك اضطرابات
هناك من يكسر المحلات تعرفونه في مثل هذه
الاعمال الاضطرابات هذا الشيء اللي متوقع
لا تصغي الى السكان الى الشعب هذه
المؤسسات هي موجوده فقط الناس يودون اسقاط
هذه
تعرفون ان هناك شبكات التلفزيونيه في فرنس
منذ الصباح حتى المساء تبثوا اشياء لمنع
الشعب من تعبير عن رايه
والرئيس فعل جيدا فقال للشرطه الوزير
الداخليه بانه اليوم لابد ان تصدر اوامر
لتخفيف الامر
وتهدئه الاوضاع
ونعرف ان هذا العمل الذي جرى هو ادى الى
اختيار الشاب صغير ولكن لا يمكن ان نتحدث
مع اشخاص سيئين وذو جنح سابقة لو سمحت
يعني اريد ان اريد ان الفت نظرك لانه جرى
حرق الفي سياره بالامس دمرت مئات المباني
هل هذا عمل عفوي باعتقادك ام كما يقول
الرئيس الفرنسي
وراءه جماعات منظمه
ان التكسير والهجوم على المحلات غير مقبول
لا يمكن قبول التدمير الممتلكات العامه
هذا امر غير مقبول لكن المشاغبين احيانا
يكسرون ولكن انا احاول فقط افهم ما الذي
حصل لماذا تعلمنا احيانا الاعمال الشغب
تنتقل بشكل بحث
يحاولون اجتياز بعض العقبات وبالتالي
يسبحون
فاعلين سلبيين
ولكن احيانا هذا يؤدي او يسمح بالتفاوض
التفاوض مع الطرف الذي لم يرغب ابدا في
التفاوض معهم طبعا كسر الامور وتدوير
الممتلكات العامه غير مقبول ولكن هذا هذا
هذه الممتلكات مشتركه لنا كلنا لكل
مواطنين وبالتالي نحن هناك
ان شعارنا هو المعادله والاخوه
وحريه باذن لابد ان نتعامل باخوه وتتعامل
باخوه وايضا بانه احدى صفوفنا ولا ان
نهاجم الطرف من الجمهور على حساب طرف اخر
دكتور حسني عبيدي لو ذهبنا الى سياق
الاوسع لما يجري عن ماذا تعبر هذه
الاحتجاجات بالعنف الذي تشهده رغم الخطاب
الاولي
للسلطات الفرنسيه التي استنكرت الجريمه
بشده من الرئيس الفرنسي الى وزير الداخليه
ورغم احاله الشرطي الذي ارتكبها الى
العداله
وتوجيه تهمه القتل العمد اليه لماذا اتت
رده الفعل على هذا الشكل وهي مستمره
لان هناك انعدام كبير للثقه بين جزء كبير
من مواطني مناطق الضواحي والنظام السياسي
وخاصه مع الشرطه دائما يرفعون شعار بان
الشرطه تقتل هناك خوف كبير عندما تقم مثلا
دوريه من الشرطه توقف شاب من المناطق
الضواحي سواء في القطار سواء في باريس او
الضواحي هناك خوف كبير لانه يعلم جيدا
بانه يمكن في النهايه ان يحصل له ما لا
تحمد عقباه النقطه الثانيه يعني لولا مثلا
لم يكن هذا اشتريت الفيديو من المؤكد ان
ربما كانت العمليه تمر بس الشرطي يقول
بانه كان في عمليه دفاع على على النفس لكن
هذا الفيديو هو الذي في النهايه فضح
الممارسات الغير القانونيه صحيح ان هناك
ارتكاب جنح من قبل هذا القاصر لكن هذا لا
يبرر عمليه القتل ولذلك انا اعتقد فعلا
بان العلاقه ما زالت غير صحيه للاسف بين
عدد كبير من هذه المناطق رغم كل الجهود
التي لم تقل بنجاح مع جزء من النظام
السياسي ومع وزاره الداخليه ونرى ذلك
المقاربه الامنيه الكبيره جدا التي تم حتى
المبالغه فيها تدل في النهايه لانه بقي
النظام السياسي في فرنسا الحكومه الفرنسيه
ما زالت الى حد الان رغم دعوات التهدئه من
قبل بعض الوزراء لكن ما زالت بقيت في نفس
المستوى وهو قضيه المعالجه الامنيه في حين
انها تعبر على مشاكل اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
جمه فعلا يعيشها شباب ليسوا من فقط موصول
جزائريين هم اصلا المواطنين فرنسيين درزوا
في المدارس الفرنسيه لكن قضيه التكافؤ
الفرص قضيه العداله الاجتماعيه قضيه
الوصول الخدمات لكل هذه المناطق بصفعه
عادله ثم سلوك اعتقد كذلك الشرطه هو الذي
اعتقد احد الاسباب الذي التي يمكن
معالجتها من قبل الحكومه الفرنسيه
انت قلت في البدايه ان في اساس هذه الازمه
ايضا الشان الاجتماعي ولكن ما حدث يطرح
سؤال عن الشارع في فرنسا في كل مره هناك
ازمه يخرج الشارع بقوه ويصطدم مع مؤسسات
الدوله راينا ذلك في اليومين الماضيين
راينا ذلك في قضيه رفع سن التقاعد راينا
ذلك في قضيه السترات الصفراء كل ذلك عن
ماذا يعبر
في الحقيقه يمكننا ان نتحدث عن نقطتين في
هذا السياق اولا بالنسبه الى ما قاله
السيد دروش هذا الخطاب منذ اربعين عاما
وصل بنا الى الوضع الذي وصلنا اليه اليوم
بالنسبه الى سؤالك حول الاحداث في الايام
القليله الماضيه هي غير مرتبطه اي ارتباط
بمساله السترات الصفراء لا نتحدث انذاك لم
نكن نتحدث عن
الضواحي تحدثنا انذاك عن الطبقه الوسطى
التي كانت تواجه مشاكل في بلادها وكانت
تبحث عن رفع الصوت انا لسوء الحظ اتفق مع
السيد الدرايش في هذه المرحله في فرنسا
يجب اللجوء الى التكسير والحرق لرفع الصوت
بالنسبه الى موضوع السترات الصفراء انتقل
الموضوع الى اعمال العنفيه في بعض الاحيان
من رجال الشرطه وفي بعض الاحيان من طابور
خامس منذ السينا بين السترات الصفراء
وراينا تصعيدا في العنف وهذا امر لم نكن
نشهده في فرنسا ولسوء الحظ هذا الامر يصبح
شائعا بشكل متزايد ولكن يجب ان نفهم
بالنسبه الى الاهداف
سيد جيرال تتحدث عن العنف وان القاسم
المشترك بين كل هذه التحركات كان العنف
وايضا سلوك الشرطه ما الذي يفسر ذلك
هذه المواجهه مع الشرطه تاتي بسبب وما
اكرره في هذه الضواحي هناك مناطق لا قانون
فيها عدد من الاشخاص يتصرفون فوق القانون
ما حصل الان هو عدم امتثال لاوامر رجل
الشرطه شرطي يطلب منا على حاجز او نقطه
تفتيش ان نتوقف نحن كمواطنين فرنسيين
يتعين علينا ان نتوقف وان نمتثل لاوامر
رجل الشرطه عوضا عن الامتثال حاول ان يهرب
وهذا ادى الى
ماساه التي وصلنا اليها في فرنسا في كل
عام اكثر من 5000 قضيه عدم امتثال تحصل مع
شخصيات مماثله هذا ما يجب ان نتنبه اليه
لا نتحدث عن ثوره سياسيه ما من دوافع
سياسيه بالنسبه الى هذا نحن نتحدث عن
اشخاص يقومون باعمال اعمال تخريب لان هذا
الشيء الرائج الان وعلى وجه الخصوص لان
الحكومه سمحت بذلك لمده سنوات يجب احلال
النظام الجمهوري في هذه المناطق وهي نقطه
اساسيه
لماذا تبدو اعمال التخريب رائجه كما يقول
ضيفا السيد جلال هل هل توافقه على هذه
القراءه
اولا انا لا اتفق اطلاقا مع ما قاله سيد
اوليفيا هو يتحدث عن الاشخاص يعيشون في
الضواحي وكانهم اشخاص متوحشون هو
ليفرق يفرق بين
الصفراء والذي يعيش في الضواحي عليه ان
نتذكر ان عندما تستمر قنوات التلفزيون
باثاره هذه الجماهير احيانا هناك اناس
يجدون هذه الوسيله الوحيده للتعبير عن
انفسهم وانا لا اعيد فكره التكسير والهجوم
ولكن انا لا اقول مثلك ان هؤلاء اشخاص ليس
لديهم خط سياسي كم كانهم هم حيوانات مره
اخرى اقول لابد ان يحترم هؤلاء الناس
للتحدث عنهم وثانيا
عفوا سيد هو لم يقلل من الاحترام ولكنه
حاول توصيف مساله معينه هو يعتبر ان ما
يجري هو بسبب عدم امتثال هؤلاء للقوانين
بالقدر الكافي
ويعتبر ان ما حدث مع نائل قد يكون السبب
وراءه لان نائل الشاب نائل الذي قتل لم
يمتثل لنقطه التفتيش الشروطيه مع قوله انه
لا يبرر لا يعتبر ان ذلك يبرر الجريمه
تفضل سيد
لكن تعلمون تعلمون لو سمحت لي لا اعرف ان
كان لديك اطفال انا لديه فتاه عمره 17 سنه
فعندما تكون من الصعب السيطره عليها
وبالتالي التشاب الذي عمره 17 سنه لا
ينبغي ان سوق السياره
الى مكان اخر اخر سيد فرانسوا اريد اريد
رايك في هذه الجمله التي قالها ان اعمال
التخريب رائجه حاليا في فرنسا
وهذه التظاهرات تحدث في هذا السياق هل
توافق على ذلك
تكسير لسماع اصواتهم امر مؤسف ربما اليوم
اولا انا اعتقد
لابد من تغيير هذا القانون القانون الذي
يسمح يعطيك السلطه كبيره للشرطه لاستخدام
الاسلحه واليوم ما اعتقد ان هناك نوافل
البرلمان قدم مشروع قرار منذ الخامس عشر
ديسمبر
لتغيير هذا القوائن واصد قانون جديد او
عرق التعديل قانون القديم بحيث لا يسمح
للشرطه بان يطلق النار كما يشاء بل ينبغي
ان يطلق النار فقط على عجلات السياره وليس
على الشخص وايضا لاولى العوده الى مشكله
التدريب كما تعلم في فرنسا لدينا
الجندارنه والشرطه وليس هناك اي قتيل يقع
بين ايدي
بايدينا ومدربون تدريبا جيدا اما الشرطه
فانه في السن الماضيه اذا قتل ثلاثه اشهر
لكن هناك اشرطه فيديو لعمر ذلك الان دخلت
الامم المتحده على خط هذه الازمه بقول
مكتب حقوق الانسان في الامم المتحده ان
السلطات الفرنسيه مدعوه الى معالجه
المشكلات العميقه المتعلقه بالعنصريه
والتمييز العنصري ولكن طبعا
رده الفعل الاولى او الاوليه من السلطات
الفرنسيه كانت رفض هذا الامر
ما مستقبل هذه الدعوه باعتقادك دكتور حسني
يعني المفوضيه الساميه يعني هي في النهايه
في دورها عندما تتحدث على مثلا القضايا
استعمال العنف المفرد في مظاهرات تعتبرها
هي مظاهرات اصلا بالمطالبه بحقوق ثم كذلك
هناك تقارير منذ فتره تصدر دائما تقارير
سواء كان مفوضيه الثانيه في جنيف او حتى
منظمات مثل حول قضيه نوع من العنصريه في
ممارسات الشرطه ليست كل الشرطه الفرنسيه
لكن هناك بعض الممارسات هذه لابد ان تعالج
صحيح انه قضيه تكوين الشرطه الشرطه مثلا
في فرنسا الشرطي بعد سنه يمكن ان يصبح
شرطي في المانيا مثلا يحتاج الى اكثر من
سنتين وبالتالي هي تركز على قضيه مثلا
تدريس حقوق الانسان تدريس بفن مواد اخرى
لتكون رادعه في النهايه لهذا لهذا العمل
النقطه اضافيه هي قضيه يعني وزير الداخليه
اعتبر تصريح مهم قال ان الثلثي الشباب
الموقوفين يعني هم اصلا مراهقين يعني من
الصعب الحديث على جماعات منظمه وكل يعني
جزء كبير من هم اصلا المراهقين كيف يمكن
ان ينظموا وانا اعتقد ان ان الشباب الذين
الشعب الذي يتظاهر المراهق هو يرى في
نفسها انه يمكن ان يكون هو نائل في
المستقبل ولذلك يعني هذا التظاهر العنيف
في النهايه وكانه هو اللغه الوحيده
المتبقيه بالنسبه لهؤلاء الشباب شكرا لك
دكتور حسني عبيدي والعلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جونيف واشكر ايضا ضيفين من باريس
سان جيرالد اوليفي البحث في العلاقات
الاوروبيه والدوليه
عداله وحقوق بلا حدود
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الى هنا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]